The trigger for jgo's gun is the same as the button on the controller 7
Then if you were to reproduce the shooting of defense and shooting without jie's gear assist, if you loved it at a distance of 100 meters, you would pull
off the rifle and
it would be a [ __ ] game that would make you burst out laughing  Is
n't that a lie? No one
plays a game A game is a game There's
no point
in being too realistic  Maybe
I had the same question and asked an acquaintance who had shooting experience.I
was confused at first, but soon I got the hang of it and started to hit Mr. b's location
[Music]
However, it's a game  After getting it, I said, "The
bullet circle is a double-edged sword. Thanks to the
assist, you can hit even if you don't aim properly
, so it's not good practice for real shooting.
On the contrary, it might slow down your arm. The
good point is poop."  Thanks to , long-distance shooting has become overwhelmingly easier.In
real life, it's extremely difficult to shoot enemies from afar.I
know, I learned it in the
tutorial, but
long-distance sniping requires a lot of calculations and experience.
Dial's sniper without an assist shoots hundreds of shots in practice, shoots, shoots, and shoots, and he
knows how the soul flies.
I looked through the scope I had set up and hit it with just my strength
That's right
I didn't put my finger on the trigger until just before the last minute So you
don't have to
red lime
1 team
ana